something a little different to start
off the show today how to destroy fake
news or really I guess what we're
talking about is a business model of
websites that are not only just
straight-up fake news but also
propaganda news websites this could be
Breitbart or other right-wing propaganda
news sites there's a very interesting
article not a new article but an
interesting one in the New York Times
which lays out sort of a strategy that
you all can participate in everybody who
uses the internet and visits news
websites can participate in this
strategy many advertisers companies they
don't know that their ads are appearing
on propaganda news websites because
they're usually buying through a middle
person some kind of an ad agency of
sorts we sometimes experience this if
you go to our YouTube channel sometimes
the ads that pop up before one of our
videos plays the ads don't make any
sense right there might be pro-gun stuff
or anti-abortion stuff of religious
stuff or ads for Republicans during
campaigns or whatever and this is
because the individual advertiser is in
controlling at the channel level which
adds which channels their ads appear on
at least not initially they're just
advertising on YouTube news & politics
channels for example this is very
frequently the same situation with
websites like Breitbart and so many
others you'll see ads there for
companies where you might see it and say
that's weird I wouldn't assume that this
is a company that is deliberately trying
to advertise on one of these news
websites and very often that's exactly
the case and tweet shaming and social
media shaming campaigns of these
companies have been very very effective
there's a Warby Parker example okay
Warby Parker which is one of our
advertisers and I glass company they
found out that their ads were appearing
on Breitbart they were buying ads
through an intermediary they were tweet
shamed they were contacted by Internet
users and they made the decision to tell
their ad buyer not to put any of their
ads on Breitbart a cut of which goes to
Breitbart and funds their operation is
this having an effect already at this
level probably not but could it have an
effect absolutely there's no doubt that
these websites are doing what they do
yes for ideological reasons in some
cases sometimes not sometimes it's for
clicks but either way it has to be
funded it has to be funded and if you
attack the way that these operations are
funded you're going to influence
negatively their ability to continue
doing this stuff I think one consequence
of this might be that companies will
continue to take on these political
positions yeah so for example Oreo is
pro-gay and chick-fil-a is anti-gay and
I guess companies having these political
takes aren't really a bad thing they're
not necessarily a good thing either but
I would imagine that that would be one
of the effects of this absolutely and I
like hearing about I mean you know
there's sort of two perspectives I don't
want to have any idea what the politics
are of a particular company if they
exist and I would I actually want
companies to be a political although
it's really hard to imagine that that's
a real thing because companies have
interests and there's no question that
they would have particular points of
view on what they want their elected
officials to do so you can choose to be
ignorant of the political views of
companies but to say I just want
companies to not be political that that
I don't think that's a realistic view
right i mean it makes sense when an oil
company comes out in favor of oil
subsidies because obviously they benefit
directly off of it but sometimes they
speak on political issues that don't
really even seem to directly affect them
indeed and that is where sometimes
people have differing opinions the other
point of view is I have a limited number
of dollars that I put into the economy
every week month year whatever so I
would rather have more information about
what the politics are of those companies
so that I can feel that every purchase
is not only a purchase that ideally is
made for a product or service that is
going to increase my well-being or
enjoyment or pleasure or whatever it's
also sort of voting in a way for a
company whose beliefs I support now as
far as Breitbart is concerned Breitbart
editor-in-chief told Bloomberg that in
spite of a number of companies in
addition to Warby Parker saying do not
put us on Breitbart that there
company continues to experience quote
exceptional growth however there have
been a number of public twitter
communications from brands which
confirmed that there are many companies
that are fleeing propaganda news and
fake news advertisers many of these
sites don't have a revenue source
outside of advertising they are not
subscription driven they're not
affiliate sales driven their ad driven
so this can absolutely impact these
companies if you take away the ability
to earn revenue or to monetize
propaganda news or fake news the ability
for the project to continue can start to
dry up and you know we were lobbied
recently by our audience Pat to stop Go
Daddy advertising people pointing out
listen you should look at some of the
things that the godaddy sounder has said
and done you should look at some of the
politics of the company you really
shouldn't be advertising this company
and we were influenced by that and we
announced that we are we ended our
advertising relationship with godaddy so
this stuff makes an impact and the
people that watch the show or very too
happy to hear that because it means that
we're being transparent and we're giving
we're listening to feedback no doubt and
that's something we've always done and
this is something you all can
participate in email the company tweet
and tag them in it you can get attention
ok you can get attention for this type
of thing and there's an interest in
doing this